why Ultra processed foods are bad for
you Ultra processed foods are foods that
you couldn't conceivably make in your
own kitchen they typically lie in the
aisles of our Supermarket the reason why
they're they're so pernicious one is
that they tend to be hyper palatable so
they tend to push our brain to a bliss
Point Beyond which self-control is
nearly impossible the brain it just like
it sends off like the equivalent of the
Fourth of July fireworks when we consume
them and so we tend to over consume them
so we get fat being overweight and obese
drives inflammation the brain sits
directly downwind of that fire which is
like essentially like a forest fire in
the body so that damages the brain being
overweight also puts you at higher risk
of type 2 diabetes which increases your
risk of Alzheimer's disease between two
and four fold having chronically
elevated blood sugar literally damages
the blood vessels that supply blood
nutrients oxygen to your to your brain
if these foods are uniquely obesogenic
then right there that in and of itself
is means that it is a threat to the
brain